elle est beaucoup plus courte qui est
une plaquette de tennis et les trousses
ans pour alléger la raquette sans
vraiment les gens plus légère une
raquette facile à manier pour un sport
encore peu connues le paddle qui peut
être prononcée pas d'elle en référence à
ses origines latines un sport moins
violent que le squash est plus facile
que le tennis où il faut agir rapidité
et attention pour la pratique c'est en
double sur un terrain légèrement plus
petit qu'un court de tennis et ce n'est
pas la seule différence en tennis on
essaie de ne jamais laisser passer la
balle
le but c'est la renvoyer la très très
régulièrement des bacs qui viennent très
fort on va essayer de justement d'aller
sait rebondir de laisser revenir sur le
mur du fond et éventuellement de la
reprendre
même en s'étant rapprochée du filet par
rapport à au point d'origine et donc du
coup on peut contre-attaqué donc en fait
quand on attaque on sait jamais si ça va
être vraiment une attaque si les
attaques a pas se retourner contre nous
et donc c'est pour ça que c'est pas un
jeu où on ne peut taper très fort sinon
si on tape fort et mal on va on se prend
la balle encore plus dur dans les dents
ensuite le pad elle serait née il ya une
trentaine d'années sur le terrain de
tennis privé d'un couple mexicain la
femme ayant du mal à frapper la balle
son mari l'aurait autorisée elle a
laissé rebondir sur le mur de la maison
avant de la renvoyer de l'autre côté du
filet que l'on y croit ou pas le padel a
bien évolué depuis
avant les muretains briques et les
balles partout pour être rapidement et
là maintenant avec les vitres on avait
cent lieues sud et les niveaux les
auteurs sur les côtés à 90 ouvert les
portes ce qui permet aux joueurs au
niveau des sorties du talent pour
ramener les balles
le pdl présente un avantage de taille
une demi heure suffit pour trouver ses
marques
si ce sport prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur en france encore peu de
structures sont dédiés à ces pratiques
et le nombre de joueurs n'est pas encore
référencé en comparaison depuis son
arrivée à la fin des années 80 en
espagne le sport de raquette fait un
tabac le pays compte trois millions de
joueurs à l'heure actuelle